we climb in nicely if feels very smooth
over James Ketchel likes a challenge but
even by his own admission flying solo
around the world in a gyrocopter
there's his toughest to date the serial
adventurer took off from Popham airfield
in Hampshire and March the 31st and now
70 days later he's halfway through his
epic journey reaching Nome in Alaska
he's flown over some of the most remote
and coldest places on earth there's no
real room for error you've got to get it
right but if you wait for the weather
it's it's not too bad
my djaro is an open cockpit gyro so it's
cold and that's that's one of the really
cold and that's one of the challenges
that that I have but it was never gonna
be easy Ketchel needs to fly 37,000
kilometers to achieve his ambition of
becoming the first person to
circumnavigate the globe solo in a
gyrocopter his flight path takes him
across Europe into Asia up into North
America and the Arctic Circle and
finally back home to England a small
aircraft travels at 70 knots and has a
range of 700 miles as the gyrocopters
are amazing you can't stall the
gyrocopter and they've been around for a
long time but you know typically people
don't fly them around the world I wanted
to sort of prove that actually these
aircraft are a lot more capable then
than people might think this latest
record breaking attempt follows quetzals
ultimate triathlon which saw him row
across the Atlantic Ocean in 2010 climb
Everest in 2011 and cycle 18,000 miles
around the world in 2013
the air building in sight it came all
the way he's described this mission as
his biggest adventure so far and hopes
it will help inspire and motivate young
people around the world to follow their
own goals as well as raising money for
charity
Ashish Joshi sky news